on prime crime when i got the call that
carl passed away
my instinctive thought was it's got to
be her
savage murder it was just shock
and dismay you couldn't believe what was
going on an elusive killer i find her to
be incredibly manipulative
and a call for justice and you put the
gun
12 to 24 inches from his head and pulled
the trigger correct
[Music]
hey there everybody i'm jesse weber and
welcome to prime crime
this is where we do a deeper dive into
the most high profile and memorable
true crime cases now this story is about
how authorities were trying to catch a
killer for years
and when they finally did you're never
going to believe what they heard
march 12 2007 may have been a normal day
for many people
but for the family of air force major
carl herrick
this was the start of a nightmare after
herring didn't report to work
law enforcement go to his home in newton
falls ohio
and discover his dead body it was just
shock and dismay we couldn't believe
what was going on authorities would
conclude that carl had been shot
three times his body found at the bottom
of a stairwell
and covered with a tarp but there was
something missing from the house
or rather someone and she wasn't around
it was very easy to put two and two
together it was very obvious what
happened
claudia herrick carl's wife was nowhere
to be found
investigators would soon find out that
their main suspect
was not only no longer in ohio she
wasn't even
in the u.s instead she had left for her
native country of brazil
days earlier when i got the call that
carl passed away
my instinctive thought was it's got to
be her
while some who knew the couple since
something might be off
carl's friend christa bridges would tell
authorities an
eerie story about claudia the year prior
to carl's death
bridges said claudia made this comment
about carl
at a bachelorette party i was eating and
then claudia just leaned over
and said if he ever left me i'd kill him
authorities learned that claudi had
purchased a gun
days before the shooting took out money
from the bank
and made a quick getaway but with
claudia now in brazil
authorities and herrig's loved ones
faced a major legal
obstacle brazil does not normally
extradite to the us for their own
citizens
he was in fact born in brazil this was a
very difficult process from the
beginning
they were not going to extradite
claudia herrig and that's when we
started talking with the local
congressman tim ryan did a really good
job
of creating publicity around this case
and then when i started the
facebook page just as for carl herrig
i had a an international audience
and many people from brazil supported
our efforts
the fight by politicians lawyers and
carl supporters to get claudia back to
the states
would last over 10 years
but then a breakthrough the brazilian
government revokes claudia's citizenship
in 2013
and in 2018 she's officially extradited
back to america
interestingly she had relinquished her
brazilian citizenship
in exchange for an american citizenship
it was touch and go
all along i was ecstatic you know now we
finally had
a chance to present the case
when herrig is finally arrested this is
where things take
a different turn so you're willing to
talk
and you're sure of that because it has
nothing to hide
i believe that claudia thought that she
could outsmart everyone
she obviously had a lot of time to think
through her answers
to almost every single question the one
thing she didn't lack was answers
herrig begins by explaining how she met
carl online
and they married in 2005. but this
relationship
at least according to her was very
strange
he won our crazy lifestyle of
doing all kinds of
perverted stuff men win everything
he forced me to play dead he would only
have an orgasm
eric said the behavior got worse boxed
with things
that he tortured me with rose
the web and he made me walk around
in the house all the time it doesn't
matter how cold it was
i thought that that description was
problematic it was when people
are telling lies that they go a few
steps too far
and she really laid it on heavy with
kink shaming
essentially i think number one to
engender sympathy
and number two to smear him to make him
look like he deserved it and that she
was being abused
herrig even blamed carl's alleged
mistreatment
for multiple miscarriages and like i
said
after a few days my body just couldn't
take it anymore
in terms of blaming him for the
miscarriages that also is bizarre
as far as i know there was no medical
proof of that of 2006 i got pregnant
again
and again he did the same thing to me
the same torch it would
be totally uncharacteristic for those
kinds of things
those things if valid should have been
brought up
ahead of time herrig explained that her
situation became
so dire particularly when she became
pregnant for a third time
that she eventually decided to commit
suicide
i'm not going to have an abortion
there's nothing that's going to
make me have an abortion and he doesn't
want to try what am i going to do
kill myself when you look at some of the
behaviors that she's exhibited in
you do see um especially some traits of
borderline personality disorder a lot of
suicidal gestures a lot of
threats for suicide attempts this is all
really consistent with what we're saying
with her
coming up next was suicide really
claudia's plan
or rather murder my plan was never not
for
one single minute to kill anybody from
my
swear to god there was enough single
minute i thought about
[Music]
that shows his character all the things
that he did to me
how he screamed at me how he cursed me
how he
leaves me after an over 10-year legal
and political battle
in 2018 claudia herrig is extradited
from brazil
back to the united states for the murder
of her husband carl herrig
who was found shot to death in his home
back in 2007
however when claudia decides to speak
with investigators on her return to
america
she accuses carl of physically and
emotionally abusing her
which led her to want to commit suicide
but listen carefully to her plan
the best way of committing suicide was
with the gun
but the downside of killing yourself
with a gun
is that it has a recoil
then most people that try to kill
themselves they they
they lose part of their face but they
don't die
yet herrig apparently had a solution
what i do i went to the gun
[Music]
right
not only that but herrig also allegedly
built a homemade contraption
to shoot herself that hole
[Music]
should be right here
i do not believe that her plan was to
kill herself
she purchased a weapon that had laser
sights
and then she went and practiced it
afraid of some phantom recoil
and then she also can built a box that
she could
steady the barrel of the gun in order to
shoot more accurately
that is not something that you typically
or ever see
in the case of suicide battered wife
syndrome is really just kind of a subset
of ptsd a person believes
that they are in extreme danger and
can't leave
that's really not been the case in this
relationship there were plenty of times
where she was left alone where she had
opportunities to leave
and that just didn't happen let's move
to the day of the shooting
claudia claimed she was pregnant for a
third time and got into a heated
argument with carl over whether to have
the child
at one point he decides to take a shower
and that's when
she decides to act something very
shocking for him
to to shake him up
so when he opened the door and see me
with the gun he saw me with a gun to my
head
that's a very uh good idea
go to the basement to do that because
you're going to splash my my paintings
you're going to splash blood
all over my paintings and
i'm not very angry if you had
said that i would be that he would be
alive
what happened next what will happen next
look at my back got very angry and i got
real freshly shocked i don't think that
this is a snap
i think that that had been carefully
contrived over years of planning
to explain away what otherwise looks
like a
cold premeditated murder
the act of shooting somebody the act of
killing somebody
takes a lot of steps and it takes a lot
of desensitization
that is not normal for most people i
don't think she snaps
it's what claudia did after the shooting
though that really cast
doubt on this attempted suicide
unintentional killing theory
first she said she wanted to shoot
herself but didn't realize
she didn't have any bullets left
then she calls her family who convinces
her to escape
and they said that um ohio
had a death penalty she goes to the bank
to drain out an account
[Music]
and before she leaves she decides to
cover up
carl's body i want to have time to
try so i put a cover over him
in case somebody came to the window
they would not see his body so i would
have time to
to continue
all this was done in very quick
succession after
the shooting which leads you to believe
that she was fleeing and fleeing
can be used as a fact to evidence guilt
if you are someone who
behaved in a rage and you felt
contrition and it was a big mistake
that was predicated upon years of abuse
which is her claim
you wouldn't necessarily run i find her
to be incredibly manipulative
i think this is what she does is she
likes to take control of situations
and she's hopeful that with her charm
and her being playful that she may be
able to get out of this
i'm already dead inside it's one thing
for law enforcement to not believe that
claudia was an abused woman who snapped
but what about a jury
i did this i killed a car
stay with us you know where that first
shot
hit you no i i actually
uh i was just shooting after her
extradition back to the united states
claudia herrig is arrested and charged
with the murder of her husband
air force major carl herrig during her
2019 trial the prosecution attempted to
show that she planned to shoot and kill
her husband
while her defense team argued this was a
spontaneous act
fueled by years of alleged abuse and
carl's indifference
towards his wife's life and she shot him
because at her moment of weakness
30 days after she's attempted suicide
when she wants to have a conversation
with her
he tells her go ahead
kill yourself moment of weakness is just
it is a term of art but it's something
that is a basically a heat of passion
defense that you are so enraged that in
that moment of weakness state
you act out upon those feelings that is
theoretically possible from the
statement that she claims
her husband made while there was no one
better than claudia herself to tell her
side of the story
did you plan to kill carl never never
never for a second yet it was when the
prosecution cross-examined herrig
that the fireworks really began
before you shot carl herrick
you were upset that he had an engagement
party for you in putin bay correct
i thought that was very weird it was a
sign that something yes or no
i'm not asking for an explanation all i
want to know is yes or no
before you shot him you were upset that
you hadn't
that he had an engagement party for you
putting back
before you shot him were you upset that
he picked out the clothes you wore
i didn't realize at the time that yes or
no
all i want to know is yes or no
[Music]
not understand the questions we're
getting you were asking me can you
answer the questions and not argue with
me please
carl herod cannot come in here and
explain
any of these situations that you testify
to correct
yes he can through the voice no he can't
can carl herod come in this courtroom
and testify
no okay thank you her behavior on the
stand is
in complete contrast to her behavior
during her interrogation
it's almost like she realizes that she's
got caught and she's lost the power
and now she's angry men and women they
can
flirt but i never had anything with him
and i have no reason to hide that
right so he he indicated to you is that
a crime
i asked the questions here i'm sorry one
way the prosecution tried to show this
was a murder
was the actual gunshot wounds themselves
you shot and killed carl herod by
putting not one
not two but three shots into his body
correct yes
all right and you put the gun 12 to 24
inches from his head
and pulled the trigger correct probably
probably well did somebody else break
into the house and shoot him too
even the crime scene the prosecution
used to show
proof of prior calculation and design
because
according to her she had shot him one
time and believed that he was
was dead upon that first shot but
evidence shows and
and she did admit that she later shot at
him
at close range additionally and made
sure
essentially that he was dead
we the jury in this case duly empaneled
and sworn our firm find the defendant
claudia see
eric guilty of aggravated murder as she
stands charged in the first count of the
indictment
i was pleased with the guilty verdict
because i think it was the right
decision
all of her her planning and preparation
was went was for not essentially they
realized that she was not telling the
truth
we completed the mission and we got
justice for carl for his family for his
friends
for all of the people that knew and
loved him you may think claudia herrig
will never step out of prison for the
rest of her life
but is that actually the case more when
we return
i think all court shows are the same
we're talking about your father
guilty or not guilty guilty think again
judge caprio rules with common sense i
was having contractions i was rushing to
the hospital inspector quinn what does
justice demand
jail and compassion i'm going to take
the
circumstances into consideration the
best court experience i've had
clearly judge he's been in a court
before get caught
in providence
hi i'm dan abrams in the exploding legal
and true crime genre
law and crime is the only network that
has it all good evening and welcome
this is a complicated case don't really
jump to conclusions welcome to prime
crime tonight another day of drama
between both sides
from multiple live trials daily to
original and compelling programming
the law on crime network is everywhere
and we invite you
inside the jury box this is law and
crime
[Music]
before you shot him were you upset that
you had had these miscarriages
i'm not understanding your question okay
five minutes one day i'm not
understanding the question
claudia herrig the woman who executed
her husband carl herrig in cold blood
and then fled the country for over 10
years was finally arrested
charged and convicted of murder at her
sentencing
we heard the moving victim impact
statements from carl's family
i want to list every moment that it has
hurt me that dad's gone
i want to talk about my beautiful kids
he never met
i want to talk about grief and missed
opportunities
but i would never be able to stop the
loss of my brother is beyond words
the fact claudia so arrogantly fled to a
foreign country
after killing my brother has been both
heartbreaking and frustrating
knowing claudia selflessly went on with
a normal life
starting a business and getting
remarried as if nothing had happened
it's difficult for me to comprehend
people that have the ability to
essentially live double lives
or commit an act like this and then move
on to something means that they're
really good at compartmentalizing
so this is something that you'll see you
know in these cold-hearted
psychopaths but it's also a trait that's
pretty characteristic and a lot of
personality disorders
we are here today for the long-awaited
culmination
of the worst possible circumstances
contemplated
in our criminal system judge logan
sentenced the then 54 year old
to life in prison but with the
possibility of parole
after 28 years as part of the
extradition agreement between the united
states and brazil
herod couldn't be sentenced to death nor
a term of imprisonment
of over 30 years i think that that deal
would never have been stricken unless it
was absolutely mandatory and it was here
i don't think that
the us would ever have their hands on
her if they hadn't made that deal
and of course they will honor that deal
i don't think that she will ever be
obviously considered for parole until
those 28 years are up
but even then parole can be denied
indefinitely
so it'll be interesting to see how the
parole board revisits this issue
in 28 years as for herrig the woman who
said she didn't care what happened to
her
her actions would say otherwise in a
legal letter after the trial
she complains that she's a victim of
gross misconduct
and blames everyone for her current
predicament including the government
and her own trial attorney what it seems
like is she's adopted
this victim mentality hoping that others
will believe
her to either gain sympathy or sways her
guilt
she also hasn't fared too well legally
her appeal has since been denied
and conviction upheld the court of
appeals
found that there was sufficient evidence
to show
prior calculation and design and
essentially essentially they
were able to show that the jury's
verdict was based upon sound evidence
in the end it was the memory of carl
herrig that led to the eventual capture
of his killer
and it's that memory that will live on
in those who knew him
he was a good friend
i really enjoyed flying with him
he was a great guy a great pilot he was
a flight instructor
and he was just a joy to be around
it is truly a tragedy
that we had to lose him at such a
young age and carl was one of the best
he truly was
claudia herrig is just one of those
defendants that gives you the chills
and i gotta tell you when she said she
was dead inside
she might be right that's all we have
for you here on prime crime leave us
your comments on instagram and twitter
with the hashtag prime
crime as always thank you for joining us
until next time
be safe
[Music]
you